قريبا نطوي صفحه عاما ونبدا عاما جديدا
والتوقعات والتقارير حول وضع العام الجديد
بدات ومناخيه يبدو ان الاتي اعظم فاذا
شعرتهم بموجه حار شديده خلال هذا العام او
حتى في العوام السابقه فانتم على وشك
استقبال ما يوصف اكثر حراره بحسب توقعات
مكتب الارصاد الجويه في المملكه المتحده
العام المقبل سيكون واحدا من اكثر الاعوام
سخونه على الاطلاق تتوقعوا الارصاد ان
تكون متوسطه الحراره العالميه اعلى بنحو
1.2 درجه مئويه مما كانت عليه في اوقات ما
قبل الثوره الصناعيه واذا صدقت التوقعات
فسيكون هذا هو العام العاشر الذي يصل فيه
متوسط درجات الحراره العالميه الى درجه
مئويه واحد على الاقل فوق ما كان عليه في
فتره ما قبل الثوره الصناعيه بين عامين
1850 و2900 فما استمراريه زياده في
انبعاثات الغازات في عالميا على من
المحتمل ان يكون العام المقبل عاما بارزا
اخر في سلسله اكثر الاعوام سخونه على
مستوى العالم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]